do you think this is something that will
continue after this night I hope so
because you've shown you can do
spider-man without dizzy on the animated
film yes we have this was a classic
win-win-win I think it was a win for
Sony I think it was a win for Disney and
I think it was a win for the fans and
and moving moviegoers the years of a
terrific relationship with Disney and a
an excellent creative partnership or
we're very very excited and July of 2021
how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel and we have
some big news about spider-man and his
future in the MCU today now let me
explain what this clip was because it's
actually a pretty big deal this was
something put on by The Hollywood
Reporter and it's called the studio
executives roundtable and this
roundtable consists of major studio
executives from the movie and TV
industries and these are the executives
Scott Stuber from Netflix Tomi Emirates
from Warner Brothers Donna Langley from
Universal Jim gianopolous from paramount
alan horne from Disney Tom Rothman from
Sony and Jennifer Salk from Amazon so
just incredibly huge executives but the
two that we want to focus on are Alan
horn from Disney and Tom Rothman from
Sony as you all saw in the opening clip
when talking about the future of
spider-man in the MCU after what they're
calling homecoming 3 which is what a lot
of us are calling spider-man 3 and after
the scheduled crossover film team-up
film that spider-man is contracted to be
a part of in the MCU is there a future
for him well Disney and Marvel Studios
continue a relationship with Sony and as
we heard Rothman say he hopes so he
thinks it's a win-win-win a win for Sony
a win for Disney and Marvel Studios and
a win for the fans and this is something
that he has said before in regards to
the new Sony Marvel deal that recently
happened was spider-man staying in the
MCU but he's never talked about it in
regards to after that and this is huge
news because there is so much that
Marvel and Sony seemingly want to do
together inside of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
we already know Tom Hollands spider-man
in the MCU is going to connect to Sony
spider-verse with more vyas and venom 2
hopefully there's a sinister six movie
coming and we've gotten word of a Spider
Woman coming as well if every
goes according to plan hopefully all of
these could exist inside of the MCU they
could all be connected which of course
is what everybody wants this opens up
spider-man to be the leader of the New
Avengers team coming up in the MCU and
the fact that both parties are admitting
that they want to continue to work
together is really really good news and
it really is beneficial for both parties
speaking as a business yes Sony does get
a good majority of the profits of the
movies however Disney does own the
merchandising rights to spider-man so if
some of you are worried that Disney is
going to want more than they currently
have and that could be a deal breaker
not likely because that's everybody's
fear right now that's why it's said to
have fallen apart in the first place
Disney wanted to own more of spider-man
than they already did for the movies
Sony said no and that's what broke the
deal however with the new deal Disney
and Marvel do get a little bit more but
the main thing is they still have Tom
Hollands spider-man and everybody loves
him he is the future of the MCU and it
looks like he's here to stay for a
pretty long time as stated in this
interview both parties want the
relationship of spider-man in the MCU to
continue even after spider-man 3 and
spider-man's crossover film so it's
looking like the fans are truly going to
get what we want
this is excellent news so let me know
how excited you are in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and notifications turned on to
stay up-to-date on the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win at Xbox one or a ps4 as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll forth